Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Thank you for being here. This week's main episode was all about Tourette's, and we were talking with Jason about that. And as I've been kind of thinking, what shall I talk to you guys about? I was thinking the idea of self-acceptance versus what we can change, what we can't change, kind of what we just need to put up with. And I was reminded of the very noises debate on social media about Stephen Bartlett saying on his podcast that having a few glasses of wine had ruined his next few days. People have not all been super supportive of that. What I will say is as someone who doesn't drink anymore, I've never drunk problematically,
嗨，欢迎来到《内在工作》（Inner Work）。我是Marianne Trent博士。感谢您的收听。本周的主集是关于妥瑞氏症的，我们和Jason聊了这个话题。当我在思考该和大家聊些什么时，我想到自我接纳与我们能改变什么、不能改变什么，以及我们必须忍受什么之间的关系。我想起了社交媒体上关于Stephen Bartlett的激烈辩论，他在播客中说喝了几杯酒毁了他接下来的几天。人们对此并不完全支持。作为一名不再喝酒的人，我想说，我从未有过酗酒问题，
I wouldn't say, but I just realised that I didn't need that in my life anymore. I don't know if Stephen Butler has reached that same stage of kind of realization. Maybe he will after this. Maybe he'll like, well, I'll show you. I'm not going to have that ruin my life anymore. I'd love to know what your thoughts are. What are your relationships or stages of change with alcohol or substances? Have you decided to put them down?
我不会这么说，但我只是意识到我的生活中不再需要它了。我不知道Stephen Bartlett是否也达到了同样的认知阶段。也许经历这件事后他会达到。也许他会想，好吧，我会证明给你们看。我不会再让它毁了我的生活。我很想知道你们的想法。你们与酒精或物质的关系如何？处于改变的哪个阶段？你们决定戒掉它们了吗？
But it's that idea of what we can optimize and what we can't optimize. This might be timely as well, because I'm recording this. this at a point where I've broken my hand. I broke my hand whilst trying to optimise myself, I guess. So I've broken my fourth metacarpal bone, which if you are not watching this on YouTube, you might be like, I don't know where that is. If you look at the back of your own hand, look at your ring finger, that bone that runs down your hand is basically where your metacarpal will be. I've been into the hand clinic today. which is over a week after I broke it, over a week after I had it x-rayed.
但这涉及到一个关于我们能优化什么、不能优化什么的想法。这可能也很及时，因为我录制这段内容时，我的手骨折了。我想我是在试图优化自己时弄断了手。我折断了第四掌骨，如果你不是在YouTube上观看，你可能不知道那在哪里。如果你看自己的手背，看无名指，那根延伸到手掌的骨头基本上就是你的掌骨位置。我今天去了手部诊所，那是在我骨折一周多之后，也是拍完X光片一周多之后。
And the medic maybe, I don't know, saw a little bit of perfectionism in me and said, oh, of all the bones that you could have broken, the fourth metacarpal is the best one to have broken because it heals really nicely. So well, far time for choosing that one to break. And I was like, it wasn't really a choice, but thank you. And I hope it does heal nicely. So mine is my right hand, so that is not ideal. But I was in there trying to just really work on my wellness.
医生可能，我不知道，看出了我身上的一点完美主义倾向，说，哦，在你可能折断的所有骨头中，第四掌骨是最好的，因为它愈合得非常好。所以，好吧，真庆幸选了这根骨头折断。我当时想，这其实不是一种选择，但谢谢你。我希望它能愈合得好。我折的是右手，所以这不太理想。但我当时确实是在那里努力改善我的健康状况。
I was in the gym. This is why the optimization came in. I was in the gym. And of course I didn't know that I'd end up having an accident and breaking my hand. That is what has happened in reality. And now it's kind of set back my goals. So yeah, I didn't know that I would end up hurting myself and then not being able to exercise. I'm able to do sit-ups.
我当时在健身房。这就是优化带来的后果。我在健身房里。当然，我不知道自己最终会发生意外并弄断手。这就是现实中发生的事情。现在它打乱了我的目标。所以是的，我不知道自己最终会伤害自己，然后无法锻炼。我还能做仰卧起坐。
Sit-ups are pretty much all I'm doing. I did think earlier now that I'm going. now that I'm a little bit less hand anxious. I could probably do some squats, but I can't run really. It's probably not safe to be running with my hand in a splint when I might fall over and injure myself again. I can't drive for six weeks.
仰卧起坐几乎是我现在唯一能做的运动。我之前想过，既然我现在对手的焦虑少了一些，我可能可以做一些深蹲，但我真的不能跑步。戴着夹板跑步可能不安全，因为我可能会摔倒并再次受伤。我六周内不能开车。
So it's encouraging me to just, I guess, accept where I am and not optimize. And I appreciate someone with a Tourette's diagnosis may not necessarily have that level of kind of optimization, sub-optimized, on days, off days, because it might not be something that they can control in the same way that you can do that. But I guess I would be interested in whether kind of mindfulness is an approach which might help someone with Tourette's. That is something I meant to ask, Jason, perhaps I'll
所以这鼓励我，我想，去接受我现在的处境，而不是去优化。我很感激，患有妥瑞氏症的人可能不一定有那种优化、次优、状态好坏的水平，因为这可能不是他们能像你那样控制的事情。但我很好奇，正念是否是一种可能帮助妥瑞氏症患者的方法。这是我本想问Jason的问题，也许我会
ask. And we can, yeah, cover that in future. But yeah, what relationship have you got? I was speaking to someone today about, I guess, that gestalt idea of when you feel like you've got to do things and then just tweaking it a little bit and thinking, well, am I getting to do that? Because am I, in fact, choosing to do that? So I guess even with the Stephen Barley example, if I'm choosing to drink alcohol, I guess more than a glass or two, then am I choosing to have disrupted sleep? Am I choosing to then be a bit cranky with my kids the next day because I'm, you know, coming out the after effects of drinking alcohol?
问他。我们可以，是的，在未来讨论这个问题。但是，你有什么样的关系？我今天和某人谈论了，我想，那种格式塔（Gestalt）理念，当你觉得你必须做某事时，稍微调整一下，思考一下，我是在“不得不”做吗？因为我实际上是在“选择”做吗？所以我想，即使以Stephen Bartlett的例子为例，如果我选择喝酒，我想超过一两杯，那么我是在选择睡眠质量下降吗？我是在选择第二天因为酒精的后遗症而对孩子们发脾气吗？
For me, I didn't choose to do that. I didn't want to, my kids didn't sleep. So when they were very young, I thought I'm not adding alcohol into the mix because any time my head hits the pillow, I want to actually be getting that benefit of the sleep. So for me, alcohol just didn't make sense in my life. And for me, it helped me just be firmer in my choices, I think. I just don't drink.
对我来说，我没有选择那样做。我不想，我的孩子们不睡觉。所以当他们很小的时候，我想我不会把酒精加进来，因为每当我的头碰到枕头时，我真的想获得睡眠带来的好处。所以对我来说，酒精在我的生活中没有意义。对我来说，它帮助我更坚定地做出选择，我想。我只是不喝酒。
It means I can drive when I can drive, when I haven't got a broken hand. I can drive whenever I want to. How will we get there? How will we get home? Well, I'll drive. It just, I don't know, it just makes things simpler. And, you know, days gone by, I think it would have made things cheaper. I don't think that's the case anymore because you can easily pay as much for a mocktail
这意味着当我可以开车时，当我没有骨折时，我可以随时开车。我们怎么去那里？我们怎么回家？嗯，我会开车。这只是，我不知道，这让事情变得更简单。而且，你知道，过去的日子里，我想这会让事情更便宜。我不认为现在还是这样，因为你可以很容易地为一杯无酒精鸡尾酒支付同样多的钱，
or even a non-alcoholic drink sometimes. I think a pint of Coke in London is about £5.50, six pounds, depending on where you buy it from. Obviously, that's at a higher end place, but that's a lot of money. That isn't, you know, well, maybe let's think about how much the alcohol would be there as well. but I would love to learn more about what your relationship is like with acceptance and optimisation and to think about how that shows up for you whether you've got any physical health or mental health diagnoses or symptoms and I would just love to learn more about that. Thank you for watching or listening to Inner Work.
甚至有时是非酒精饮料。我想在伦敦一杯可乐大约要5.50英镑或6英镑，取决于你在哪里买。显然，那是在高端场所，但这确实是一笔钱。那不是，你知道，好吧，让我们也想想那里的酒精会花多少钱。但我很想更多地了解你与接纳和优化之间的关系，并思考它是如何体现在你身上的，无论你是否有任何身体健康或心理健康诊断或症状，我很想更多地了解这一点。感谢您观看或收听《内在工作》。
The next episode will be available on Wednesday evening. Now, at the moment, I'm just trying to get myself into a predictable pattern. I think it's going to be around 7.30pm on a Wednesday evening. And I think that will happen both on YouTube and wherever you get your podcasts at the same time. I think that's the plan. But again, I love your feedback on this. You know, I don't get everything right all of the time. So originally, I launched in a work as a member-only service where you guys paid to get these
下一集将于周三晚上发布。目前，我只是试图让自己进入一个可预测的模式。我想大约是在周三晚上7点30分。我想这会同时在YouTube和你们获取播客的任何平台上发布。我想这就是计划。但同样，我很期待你们的反馈。你知道，我不可能一直都做对。所以最初，我将《内在工作》作为一个会员专享服务推出，你们付费来获取这些
episodes, but I just thought, you know what, I would sooner, if I'm creating the content, I'd sooner get listened to, get watched, you know, so every day is a school day. And I guess maybe this is part of my optimization journey as well. Thank you for being here. Thank you for choosing to be a listener or a viewer on inner work. And I'll look forward to bringing you the next episode next week. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
剧集，但我只是想，你知道吗，如果我在创作内容，我宁愿被听到、被看到，你知道，所以活到老学到老。我想也许这也是我优化之旅的一部分。感谢您的收听。感谢您选择成为《内在工作》的听众或观众。我期待下周为您带来下一集。保重。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。